♪ ♪
>> Tucker: IT'S HARD TO
OVERSTATE THE DAMAGE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS DONE TO THE
UNITED STATES OVER THE PAST
COUPLE OF WEEKS.
THEY ABANDON HUNDREDS OF
AMERICAN CITIZENS IN AFGHANISTAN
INCLUDING SCHOOL CHILDREN EVEN
AS THEY IMPORTED THOUSANDS
OF UNVENTED AFGHAN TRIBESMEN
INTO THE UNITED STATES.
ON THE WAY OUT IS ONE FINAL
INSULT, THEY ARMED TO THE
TALIBAN WHICH IS ONE OF THE BEST
EQUIPPED ARMIES IN THE SIZE OF
THE WORLD.
IT'S BEYOND BELIEF.
MOST PEOPLE ARE STUNNED BY
APPEARED WE HAVE TO BE HONEST
AND TELL YOU THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DID NOT DO THIS
ALONE.
THEY HAVE HAD A LOT OF HELP OVER
A VERY LONG TIME FROM THE
RECKLESS NEOCONSERVATIVES THAT
RUN OUR FOREIGN POLICY
ESTABLISHMENT.
THE MAIN REASON AMERICANS WERE
SO SHOCKED BY THE FALL OF KABUL
LAST WEEK IS THAT FOR YEARS
PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON HAVE BEEN
LYING TO THEM ABOUT IT.
AND TELLING THEM EVERYTHING IN
AFGHANISTAN IS JUST FINE.
IT'S IMPROVING, FOREVER
IMPROVING.
OUR SACRIFICE IS WELL WORTH IT.
OUR STRATEGY IS SUCCESSFUL.
JUST KEEP SENDING US MONEY ON
YOUNG SOLDIERS AND WE WILL MAKE
THE WORLD SAFER AMERICA.
FOR DECADES, THAT'S WHAT THEY
HAVE BEEN TELLING US.
ONE OF THE MAIN MOUTHPIECES FOR
THESE LIES HAS BEEN
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM OF
SOUTH CAROLINA.
GRANDMA IDENTIFIES AS A
REPUBLICAN BUT HIS VIEWS IN REAL
LIFE ARE INDISTINGUISHABLE FROM
TONY BLINKEN OR MARK MILLEYS, HS
OR HER WET WASHINGTON, NOT
IN SOUTH CAROLINA.
WE HAVE PULLED TOGETHER THREE
REPRESENTATIVE SOUND BITES THAT
TELL YOU THE STORY OF
LINDSEY GRAHAM'S PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE DEBACLE
NOW ON DISPLAY IN AFGHANISTAN.
HERE IS THE FIRST OF THEM FROM
12 YEARS AGO, AND AUNT GRAHAM
EXPLAINS AS A OBAMA SUPER FAN,
HE IS IN FAVOR OF SENDING 35,000
TROOPS TO FIGHT A WAR DESPITE
THE FACT HE KNOWS PERFECTLY WELL
THAT MANY OF THEM WILL DIE.
WATCH.
>> WHEN IT COMES TO AFGHANISTAN,
I AM COMPLETELY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE PRESIDENT-ELECT'S DECISION
TO SEND 35,000 TROOPS INTO
AFGHANISTAN.
I WOULD LIKE EVERY AMERICAN TO
KNOW THAT NOT ONLY ARE THE
TROOPS NEEDED, UNFORTUNATELY
CASUALTIES ARE LIKELY TO
INCREASE, BUT WE HAVE A
GAME PLAN IN AFGHANISTAN THAT I
THINK JUSTIFIES THE EXPENDITURES
OF BLOOD AND TREASURE THAT IS
ABOUT TO COME.
>> Tucker: NUZZLING WITH OBAMA
TELLING US, UNFORTUNATELY
CASUALTIES WILL INCREASE, BUT WE
HAVE A GAME PLAN IN AFGHANISTAN
THAT I THINK JUSTIFIES THE
EXPENDITURES OF BLOOD AND
TREASURE.
SO NOW IS A MOMENT TO ASK,
REALLY, LINDSEY GRAHAM, WHAT WAS
THE GAME PLAN?
IN A WHAT POINT DID YOU REALIZE
THAT IT WASN'T WORKING?
WELL, IF LINDSEY GRAHAM EVER
KNEW THAT HIS PLANS WERE
FAILING, SOMEHOW HE FORGOT TO MN
IT TO THE REST OF THE COUNTRY.
SO HERE IS TWO YEARS LATER
TELLING US THAT WE ARE REALLY,
REALLY CLOSE TO WINNING IN
AFGHANISTAN.
AND NOT JUST IN AFGHANISTAN, BUT
ALSO IN TUNISIA, EGYPT, LIBYA,
SYRIA, AND YEMEN.
THIS CLIP IS HARD TO WATCH, BUT
PLEASE, MAKE YOURSELF.
>> WE ARE ON THE VERGE, IN MY
VIEW, OF TURNING THIS THING
AROUND.
I SEE AFGHANISTAN, TUNISIA,
EGYPT, LIBYA, SYRIA, YEMEN AS
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITIES TO
CHANGE THE WORLD FOR THE BETTER.
IF WE AS CONGRESS ACCELERATE THE
WITHDRAWAL SCHEDULE BECAUSE IT
IS POPULAR AT HOME, WE WILL
UNDERCUT ALL OF THE GAINS WE
HAVE MADE.
>> Tucker: SO THE BEAUTY OF
VIDEOTAPE IS THAT IT LIVES
FOREVER.
THAT WAS TEN YEARS AGO.
AFGHANISTAN, TUNISIA, EGYPT,
LIBYA, SYRIA, YEMEN,
LINDSEY GRAHAM DESCRIBED THEM
ALL AS LITTLE LABORATORIES TO
TEST HIS THEORIES.
ALL OF THOSE PLACES STILL EXIST
AND ARE STILL COUNTRIES.
THE QUESTION IS, HOW ARE THEY
NOW?
HAS ANYONE OF THOSE COUNTRIES
BEEN IMPROVED BY
LINDSEY GRAHAM'S GAME PLAN?
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION, YOU HAVE
TO ASK THE PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN
THOSE COUNTRIES.
MANY OF WHOM HAVE SINCE BLED AS
REFUGEES TO GERMANY AND
SACRAMENTO, CALIFORNIA.
LINDSEY GRAHAM HIMSELF WEIGHED
IN ON THE RESULTS OF THE
GAME PLAN.
HE DOES NOT LIKE TO LOOK
BACKWARD.
REFLECTIONS SUGGEST A
COUNTABILITY.
IF THERE IS ONE THING THAT
LINDSEY GRAHAM IS STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO, IT IS THAT.
INSTEAD, BY THE SPRING
LINDSEY GRAHAM HAD DROPPED THE
TALK OF WINNING THE WAR AGAINST
TERRORISM OR BRINGING DEMOCRACY
TO THE GREAT UNWASHED.
THOSE WERE YESTERDAY'S GOALS.
THE NEW JUSTIFICATION FOR
KEEPING TROOPS IN AFGHANISTAN
WAS THE FIGHT FOR GLOBAL
FEMINISM.
WE SENT MARINES TO KABUL TO TEAR
DOWN THE PATRIOTIC CREE,
LINDSEY GRAHAM TOLD US.
KEEP IN MIND THAT HE SAID THIS
WITH A STRAIGHT FACE INTO THE
CAMERA.
IT IS AND HERE IS THE STATUS OF
ALL THE MOVES, AS DIFFICULT AS
AFGHANISTAN HAS BEEN AND WILL
BE, THINGS HAVE CHANGED.
I WENT OVER RIGHT AFTER THE FALL
OF THE TALIBAN, TODAY THERE ARE
OVER 6 MILLION WOMEN WHO HAVE
BEEN EDUCATED, KABUL IS A VERY
COMMERCE-DRIVEN AREA.
PEOPLE CAN SING AND DANCE AND
LIVE THEIR LIVES WITHOUT THE
OPPRESSION THAT THE TALIBAN
BROUGHT ON THEM.
>> Tucker: HE HAS BEEN GOING
THERE FOR 20 YEARS PAID WE ARE
SAID TO TELL YOU TONIGHT THAT
LINDSEY GRAHAM'S DREAM HAS DIED,
THE LESS GENDER STUDIES CLASS IN
AFGHANISTAN HAS SHUTTERED ITS
DOORS.
EVERYONE IN THAT COUNTRY IS NOW
THOROUGHLY BINARY.
THE QUESTION WAS THE WHOLE
EXPERIMENT WORTH IT?
WE WOULD LOVE TO KNOW WHAT
LINDSEY GRAHAM THINKS ABOUT
THAT.
WE SEE HIM ON TELEVISION ALL THE
TIME, HIS NEVER ENDING
FUND-RAISING TOUR.
I'M A CONSERVATIVE, SEND ME
MONEY.
IT'S PUBLIC TELEVANGELIST
IMPAIRED BUT HE WON'T COME ON
THE SHOW, AND THAT'S